here's what would happen if men could  get pregnant  first off you'd need to have a  fertilized egg implanted into your body  your abdominal cavity would be a good  spot  if implanted at the right time an embryo  could possibly attach itself to any  living tissue it finds like a kidney  liver or even spleen your biggest  problem would be detachment with a  pregnancy in your abdomen you'd need  some very challenging surgery to remove  the placental material you could have a  hemorrhage or internal bleeding  if you used an implanted uterus the two  major surgeries you'd have to go through  would have high risks of complication  it would be possible although it's never  been done but some medical experts say  this might be in our near future if men  who let's face it dominate business  politics and lawmaking could get  pregnant it might make abortion and paid  pregnancy leave easier to access so